can you still hear him no just you
which luca actor recorded most of the
film from their mom's closet
we see the final product but behind the
scenes recording remotely
during a pandemic looks very very
different than normal
this was actually the first time some of
these actors had ever done voice work
today we're checking out the performers
behind the voices that brought us disney
pixar's
luca i know your problem you got a bruno
in your head
a bruno jacob trombley is only 14 years
old
but already a total pro in the film
world
he's done roles in live action movies
like room and wonder
however voice work is a very different
experience and discipline
for trombley it wasn't too much of an
issue anyway since he has
years of experience doing it he's been
the voice of pete for the past few years
in
pete and the cat and of course he will
also be voicing flounder in the upcoming
live-action remake of the little mermaid
his animated voice really brings this
hilarious moment to life
[Music]
seeing emma berman performing behind the
scenes makes it so hard to believe that
she's still pretty new to the business
this is actually her first major project
are you in town for the race
the puerto roso while the trio may just
be meeting it feels like they're
already at the beginning of a great
adventure and friendship together
emma berman's sweetness comes through on
the screen and behind the scenes
which is extra impressive considering
she's not acting opposite anyone
jack dylan grazer has done plenty of
movies and tv shows already
i've been doing this forever but it's
still early days for grazer when it
comes to voice over performance
it's it's it's been so much fun it's
really hard it really has so
for him it was a big adjustment since he
couldn't actually
look at the people he was acting
opposite however
he really got into it and as we can see
was definitely able to get his point
across luca
it's simple just don't listen to stupid
bruno this pep talk
works fortunately it wasn't as
drastic for tremblay himself as it
happened behind the scenes
but he managed to portray the panic
extremely well
he's dead i killed him the worry that
he'd lost his best friend comes through
perfectly in his voice here this kind of
acting should be helpful when he's
taking on flounder who goes through
plenty of panic of his own
alberto communicating the fact that he's
a sea monster
could definitely be tricky but somehow
newcomer grazer does a spot on job
it's fine i'm not human what's even more
impressive about this performance
is that it was done out of his mom's
closet very very
very far from this quaint italian town
however grazer had actually just been in
italy only two months before he
discovered he'd gotten the part filming
another project
so luckily everything in his life felt
pretty in sync and he could feel those
italian vibes
wait it's called phantom tail he'll get
used to it
watching berman behind the scenes is so
exciting because she's so animated while
she's performing
we can see how it emanates what her
character does on screen perfectly
julia is an optimistic girl but even she
has her doubts about the abilities of
these sea monsters
and understandably so you can't swim
you can barely ride a bike saturn
disaster
we wouldn't be a fan of disastrous
either how alberto learned to walk
so well we're not entirely sure but he
seems pretty well versed when it comes
to it
luca does have a great and enthusiastic
teacher
even though his instructions might not
be the most helpful sometimes
walking is just like swimming but with
no fins or tail
and also there's no water the chemistry
between alberto and luca is really
special
which is extra impressive since the
actors haven't actually met in person
that's right they developed this
beautiful on-screen friendship and all
without ever actually speaking face to
face
it was like oh wow emma berman makes for
a
very good trainer maybe even better than
alberto
there was no hesitancy in getting them
into shape the boys are definitely being
well prepared by her as she's
clearly thought of everything can you
dodge obstacles
what if an old lady crosses your path we
would just
love to see berman and her co-stars
performing the scene live as well
learning how to ride a bike is a pretty
amazing feeling for anyone
but especially for a sea monster who
let's remember
also just learned how to walk trombley's
enthusiasm
radiates behind the scenes julia said
look up
and then all of a sudden i was writing
it we can see that he and luca are
very similarly animated in their
performance the town will cheer our
names
erkola's life will be ruined once julia
has her mind set on something
there is no turning back we can feel
just how excited not only julia is
but berman the actress herself it was
definitely really really good
the enthusiasm about working with her
new friends and feeling re-inspired
really comes through in this scene they
definitely sound like winners
that's why we gotta win one of the
sweetest moments in the whole movie
is definitely when luca describes the
dreams of his adventures with alberto
around the world
every day me and alberto are gonna ride
someplace new
it's a touching and tender moment that
translates beautifully to the screen
trombley's presence comes through behind
the mic and we can hear
every single sweet note and every night
we'll sleep under the fish julia is one
of the most
organized and determined kids that we've
ever seen
i actually relate to her in some ways
considering her positivity and how well
she motivates the team it seems like
their chances are pretty good
we have one week to train bronte a
fourth
they won the enthusiasm award for sure
we love seeing berman's physicality
behind the mic she embodies the
character of julia perfectly
too much my mom says sometimes i'm too
much no way
not for me jim gaffigan is usually a
stand-up comedian
so it makes sense why his performance is
so strong
and his comedic timing so on point all
right young man
you're not fooling anyone his sneak
attack on this unexpecting italian child
brings a hilarious moment to the movie
one that gaffigan portrays perfectly
it's
time for us to go home his energy behind
the mic
really amps the scene up this moment
under the fish
or stars depending on if you're a human
or a sea monster
is a pretty magical moment no matter how
you look at it
it's my favorite berman's performance is
genuine and
full of sweetness we can really
understand how luca would become
so excited by the world and all of its
wonders seeing it through julia's eyes
this is how machines fly see and they're
big towns called city so
cool right when she's on land luca's mom
daniella does not hold back
even her husband lorenzo is a bit
nervous by her boldness
gaffigan's hesitant performance is very
obvious behind the mic
as well honey no i
i don't it's amazing that his chemistry
with maya rudolph was so
strong even though they didn't get to
act with each other directly
we look horrifying ugh gross
voice over acting takes such skill but
these actors have done an
incredible job at bringing the
characters to life it's so surprising to
know that this was grazer's first time
doing animation
we have no doubt that he'll be doing a
lot more in future
what was your favorite behind the mic
moments forever